that's
hello good morning good afternoon good
evening and welcome to psycheck your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
we have a full house we are we are all
in today so welcome Matt say hello Matt
hello Matt shut up Matt uh hey stormy
how are you mentioned hello
and we have the young American I can do
this there we go Harris
so we have a lot to talk about today we
are going to be chatting an awful lot
about Stargate because it is our
Stargate Sunday episode so let's get
into it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
before we start talking about Stargate
though we'll do what we always do what
we've been watching guys
just around the course of Wednesday
right Wednesday Wednesday
I do want to quickly talk about this
because I have as you know poo pooed
Timber I have more than once said that
Tim Burton keeps taking really good
ideas and Tim Burton them and ruins them
um I love Wednesday I I absolutely adore
it you guys have said a few bits what do
you think what you think stormy before
we get into it
about Wednesday yeah
it's we're also used to having
trepidation for whatever new thing comes
around oh thank you Shelly I love you
so we all have these Trevor days like oh
here's this cool idea but oh someone's
gonna screw it up it's going to be
terrible I'll be vomiting by my bedside
for a month but Wednesday
was damn awesome
I threw my back out trying to do the
Wednesday dance you know and I'll
probably be in a brace for the next
month but it was really good you know
Tim Burton not a slouch of course
right
right and I in the the the
um Ortega I think her name is the
actress yeah
yeah
exceptional exceptional
and you know Christina Ritchie so
exceptional you know I really like the
way that they um
they uh put her you know they wrote a
new role for her and I don't want to
give any spoilers away but
very very very good I I just can't say
that episode she's just gone into the
clicky thing and That Was Then third
episode in so I don't know
I love that so much you're in for a good
time I never saw Christina Ricci never
became quite like an A-list celebrity
that she always sort of destined to be
as a child actually she's never quite
you know didn't like that yeah there was
this one show that was that she was the
the featured actress in of the
television show called Pan Am
it ran for like I think 10 episodes here
in the states and it was really good but
for whatever reason it never no pun
intended Pan Am never took off but she
was really good at it
I mean her acting skills are just are
awesome but it's just
yeah I don't know like uh she was great
it really had really edgy things like
Prozac Nation back in the day and it's
just I don't know maybe just Hollywood
doesn't work
isn't she
um when I was growing up
she was doing Casper as I was growing up
too which was great another franchise
under her belt you know but you grew up
last week
I like the little things in Wednesday
like the no blinking thing you know it's
like apparently she didn't blink in one
scene and Tim Burton noticed and went
that's what she should do just don't
blink and I when when the actress was
told that she was like you seriously
know I don't have to I can't blink in
any scene now and you don't notice it
but once you notice it's like yeah
that's something Wednesday would do
[Music]
it was in like episode two or three or
something it was just before the camera
pan to her literally a split second you
saw her blink like to start her take I
saw it it's like oh I see what you do I
see what you did
and what do you actually think of the um
passive
automatic
I mean General tag is amazing yeah I I
didn't know anything about her
before don't know what she's been in
before that I would have seen
as it seems I did have a quick look at
her like IMDb
and it's all stuff like
kids stuff basically so I would I would
have been a little bit too old oh
did you do in the washing
yeah it was all stuff that I probably
wouldn't have I've been interested in
but no I think she's perfect for the
role
you know the only question I don't know
what you guys think the only cast and I
think they got wrong in this movie is
Gomez
I think the guy they got to play Gomez I
don't know if he's a mate of Tim
Burton's or what but other than that
there's Morticia oh come on yeah
um there's a very Gomez
um Centric episode coming up that you'll
see and it's pretty good
yeah I I think he's creepy
I don't like him at all in it but other
than that it's Glory's of course
is good in it too yeah
good yeah I love Louise Guzman we look
more tissue
yeah we like Morticia very much
um just give me one second chance
one second
when I'm frozen
for myself
can anyone read lips
[Laughter]
my wife's got Hazzard to do but I was
just actually going to vary politely if
she wouldn't mind going away
prepared collecting right
um it's presenting what you guys want to
talk about because there is Willow but
yeah we've got a lot to get through
start again
I'd like to if I'm gonna
I'd like to talk about just a lot of
some of the things I saw this week and
uh particularly about watching the
peripheral
and um
that is I think it's an underrated show
so far I mean the uh I talked to a
cousin of mine last night he said oh
yeah that's the that's the TV show about
the video game
but the only thing in episode one
haven't you yeah well let's thought
about a video game
and um
it is
I mean it reminds me a lot of um snow
crash and it reminds me a lot of uh uh
Neuromancer a lot of uh
yeah
right right right right a lot of really
um
I don't know
um
cyber action in films or something you
know not not
not like in the vein of Johnny Mnemonic
but you know if this if
this should have been what Johnny or
Johnny Mnemonic should have been what
this show is anyway yeah I really want
to pimp out um
it's the best Thai brand sort of yeah at
the moment I think it's it's the best
like pure Sci-Fi show either at the
moment I think it's I think it's
absolutely fantastic
um
so far I'm into episode four and there's
not a sex scene which is it just
occurred to me a little bit earlier like
didn't even notice you know and so it's
not like they're just using um rats as
you know some uh sex symbol it's a
really gritty
um it's almost it kind of reminds me of
Ozark but without the drugs
you know
um
oh my God Jesus you sound like a dollar
is it a robot
man that was bad
so while he fixes his mic you know I
also start some other things and start a
video there's a new expansion for
Warcraft out dragging a flight I started
that
um watched a little bit of good doctor
it's a story about the surgeon that is
uh autistic uh finally got around to
watching Captain Phillips I'm the
captain now you know that was kind of
quirky
um also started watching a couple of the
uh
uh episodes of The Purge The Purge the
the television oh
I'd love the movie never caught it
can you hear me oh I can hear you you
just don't say anything important
[Music]
perfectly quipped
that's another pause I'm just gonna wait
for him to ask if I can hear me
we love you stormy I'm so glad you've
come back oh thank you Mary man I'm so
glad I'm not working 12 straight days
yeah I'm gonna ask is peripheral is it
is it both Nolan and joy Jonathan Nolan
and Lisa Joy as wife
same same team behind Westworld I
believe right you don't know but I
assume so I don't know I know Jonathan
Nolan it's because it's his production
company okay so but yeah
but anyway my God how many different
interesting cops do you have Harris you
can't watch why I got a Comic-Con
yesterday you know
that's freaking amazing just buy a cup
for God's sake
a white ceramic cup my friend right so
before we get into
the other couple things I did want to
talk about Stargate there was a dial the
gate episode last night
and which we've talked about a little
bit on the channel today because
um they mentioned Side Track once or
twice
um I know Matt you've seen it Harris
have you had a look I haven't yet we'll
tell you about it it's very good and I
think stormy you've had a little bit of
a look-see
um you need to you need to set aside two
and a half hours because it's a very
long watch but it's it's good
um Jennings diving is the guest who
actually used to work for MGM she now is
a consultant for lots of things and she
really knows the stuff she actually
physically knows these people I have
been asked a couple of times now whether
she is the source that I keep speaking
to and she isn't
um so I I've never spoken to Jenny but I
want to so if everybody wants to get in
there
um uh well Matt you've already found her
on Twitter I'll be finding her on
Twitter later so um we love you Jenny
come talk to us please we should get we
should literally get her on side track
that would be so cool I will ask that
well she's the thing I love about this
this
um video last night was um the guy from
dial the gate and the guy from
um gate world
never mentioned Side Track once they
would not mention they kept even when
they asked it a really loaded question
should it was probably supposedly from
one of the um people watching and sent
the question in I'm sure it's true
um that there's a certain channel that
we're going to give a shout out to and
then they don't mention it and then they
said is it clickbait or do they actually
have sources and she went they've
definitely got sources and then
mentioned side track again but she
mentioned side truck every two or three
minutes it was the best advert for this
channel
it's just like so we've done two videos
with asking people to go and have a look
at it because it is actually genuinely
brilliant video and this Jenny
genuinely knows a stuff
um but it is just like it's like she's
been watching this Channel and just
repeated what this Channel's been saying
for 12 months oh she's definitely been
watching She's definitely watching well
yeah she even knew how many subscribers
we had
she literally listed a load of channels
it was like oh yeah so I track's got 14
000 this other one's got 12 right how
the hell do you know that you you
subscribe somewhere it's always a sign
of a really good talented stalker when
they know how many subscribers you have
and so it won't get anything yeah yeah
it was when she um started reeling off
my address and my inner leg measurements
I started to get a bit concerned but um
you you Saucy little thing you know why
you know as well
um but yeah but honestly guys um we put
a video on it a little bit earlier that
Matt threw together because I thought it
might be a bit no no no no no if I did
it
um so I met through a quick video
together there's a link to the
description there that you can go and
check out the video
um and yeah but it wasn't a quick video
to be ages because I had to literally
well actually I had to I enjoyed
watching it but trying to find like the
time stamps and then like then like edit
it down oh God is it this state of the
gate December 2022 special yes yeah okay
perfect so yeah give it a go give it a
look
um and like I said they alluded to the
the next they basically said at the end
of it the next time you'll see us will
probably be in like March April blah
blah doing this again and then she said
oh actually we might want to do it in
January I was like that's what literally
what we've been saying on this channel
um I've had a little bit of an update on
that actually
um in that it might be a little bit
later than January I've I've said New
Year on purpose
um because it's very much around MGM
plus
um MGM plus transfer date might be
getting pushed back
so we'll have to see on that but if it
does get pushed back I could see this
getting pushed back but the big thing
we're waiting on is the MGM head of
movies and they still haven't
um hired anyone
but they've just shifted a couple of
people out the rumors it's to allow the
person to come in so once they come in
and they get but that leads nicely into
actually the first thing I wanted to
talk to you guys about
today the reason why ahead of movies for
MGM is important because the big rumor
I'm being held at the moment is and
actually this is something Jenny
survival spoke about in the video
yesterday
was that plan a for Amazon was always to
do a movie first and then a TV series
I'm actually hearing it might be movie
which I said we all assume that would
mean straight to Amazon movie because
that's what Amazon do right
but now we know Amazon want to do movies
straight to cinema
so
I'm being told that maybe actually they
might be pushing for a straight to
cinema movie
um first of all just let's start off the
bat what do you think about that do you
think Stargate is a big enough name that
if they did a movie it would be
successful
I think yes based on the original movie
um
because the original movie did so well I
mean the TV series did very well as well
but I think the original movie
we live in an age of reboots at the
moment where they they redo movies all
the time so I think if they did
a Stargate movie it would have that kind
of Gravitas of Stargate is back and it's
it's on the big screen and because
people who had watched the original
movie in 94 would be like yeah I need to
see that they may not have seen the this
TV series
I'm guessing majority people probably
would have done but there'll be people
that haven't
so you'll get that cross-pollination of
people who haven't seen the series and
people who have
get inside about it so I think it would
be a it'd be good thing it'd be a good
thing they've got a good baked in
audience already and then the baked an
audience they already have
seem to be pretty big fans so that word
of mouth is well if it's a good movie
the word of mouth will be really good I
would assume at least which will help
the only thing I've got slight issues
with is if they do the movie is it going
to be a continuation from the original
movie or is it going to be continuation
from the series
or you know it could just be a whole new
kind of thing you know the launching
point of a completely new episodic
series that we just can't imagine right
now yeah but that is one of the options
to us because the way the way I'm being
told they want to do is that Amazon
apparently are obsessed with Disney they
um they look at what Disney are doing
we've talked about these loadstorms in
that they wanted to do like a Marvel
style franchise
uh where it would be movies TV series
and they're all like intermixed with
each other sort of thing um but Amazon
look at Disney and think that's that's
the way that that's what they want to do
they they only consider they only see
Disney's their competitor they don't
really see anybody else
um they don't really follow Netflix's
model at all
um
so
if they did do that I I just think a
movie to Kickstarter is is the only way
they can go but if you're kickstarting a
franchise right I I'm still saying this
in a video but if they just start a
series
how do you get new fans to come and
watch it we'll go crazy we'll be like
[ __ ] yeah Stargate
yeah put Michael Jack poke Michael
Jackson Don't Put Michael Jackson
put Michael Shanks in it okay we'll
watch that [ __ ] but how do you how do
you get in new subscribe new people to
watch it
well I mean the the old trying true
method is advertising or just though
Jason Momo at it you know put him in
there for like 30 seconds all we got all
all of a sudden it's uh it's uh more
people than you can possibly imagine but
yeah you know like I imagine like a
Jason Momoa you know that would I mean
you know he start kind of got his start
with Atlantis and he probably is the
at this point the biggest star out there
I mean how many
how many uh new shows has he had you
know there's Frontier you know there's c
c was just amazing
series like him as a runner that would
be oh my God right I love that
well there's already just such a huge
cast to draw from from SG one two
Michael Rooker is in an episode as a
colonel at some point oh yondu himself
could have a series if we really wanted
to
listen here I have something great I
don't know about SGU but me not win give
her her own show she's still alive I
mean there's a whole slew of things so
is that is that Camille Ray
I don't know the characters from SG you
you just mentioned a name
um
okay
this is a very background she's like
politician he sort of characteristic but
yeah yeah I really liked him she was one
of my favorite characters I like her she
was she was one of the um one of those
characters that
kind of
wrench in the works as it were all the
time and it made for interesting
watching
um
so my thinking is that like with the
setting up a franchise is that um you've
got to start big and and if you can
bring in the Gators really easily we'll
watch it but they have to attract
another audience they have to attract I
think Jenny's stuck with this yesterday
they have to bring in that sci-fi
audience and then hopefully the the like
the Star Wars fans and things like this
you know those people that are even
beyond that sort of thing
um and the way to do that is for what a
big movie if they advertise it right
will attract people because people like
going to the cinema yeah
um and but then you have to bring in the
right actors now there's these rumors
that they were trying to get Chris
Hemsworth to do to be the lead man to be
the Richard Dean Anderson for the new
series
because I I for me again by the way guys
you think I think they need to bring in
somebody that's a big enough name that
you're going to know who it is
but not so big that they won't do the TV
series as well
so I mean we've got to find that
somebody in between I don't know if you
guys have any any suggestions on who
actually looking back on Chris Hemsworth
I can completely see why they were going
with that
um but they came in with a Witcher which
came in with a solid offer and he went
with that but
um
I think they need a likable middle of
the road b list actor I think to sort of
like Get get it going sorry yeah I think
they'd need the
not necessarily go for massive names
because you don't I don't know I don't
want to watch it just because it's got a
massive name in it I I like a show where
I don't know anything about the person
before like Wednesday for example I knew
nothing about General Ortega now I
absolutely love her
like
that's the best example I can give of
things I've watched recently
just have the right people essentially
the right people not because they're big
and not because they can bring in a huge
one it's just the right people that can
do a really good job
Jay mentioned uh Amazon wants to be you
know more like Marvel
and I I I I kind of feel that that is
how their their Company's trying to
Trend Amazon is but this last week week
and a half has been a kind of a
tumultuous concerning all of that Bob
Iger is now in at Disney you know and
how that will affect everything going
forward is yet to be seen he will he
certainly has a different he had a
different Creative Vision when he was
running dizzy before he stepped down uh
and then we I've heard rumors of
Kathleen Kennedy stepping down how is
that her name is like executive producer
of damn near everything over especially
Star Wars
and then this last month Amazon lost a
trillion dollars in market value right
and they're getting ready for massive
layoffs like 20 000 people coming up
and how is all you know Amazon has these
goals right you know to be the next
Marvel I think I mean maybe it's it's
presented that way maybe not admittedly
you know from work from from their own
PR but that's you can kind of see that's
the direction you're going how does you
know the the the you know Bob Iger is
kind of a competitive guy how did you
know with the the Kathleen Kennedy spent
stepping down Bob Iger coming on board
and
um
Amazon losing a trillion dollars in
market value how do you guys think
that's really going to affect uh Prime
video going forward especially with all
these projects
I think the Prime video financial
situation is a bit unweed though because
their value was so massively over
inflated during covid and because
everyone stayed at home so everybody
bought stuff off Amazon I mean there and
and I think they hired massively to keep
up with that demand I can't imagine they
ever thought
it would continue
but that did create sort of a false
um inflated value
but all of the stream and services have
now got massive problems
um Disney are um are losing 500 million
dollars a quarter thanks to Disney
ouch Paramount plus are genuinely at
risk of
um going under Paramount a genuine risk
again they they owe 16 billion dollars
[Music]
is they have a revenue of about four
and that's total revenue so they're in
trouble but they have managed to get
their debt down it wasn't only 20
billion at one point
um
you know all this HBO Max is even
actually worse off there in I mean
that's why this HBO Discovery merges
happened it's because they desperately
needed to cut costs
you know so all of the stream Services
regardless of where they are there are
Financial issues I think there was a
streaming bubble
and it's about to pop
do you think that's why tiger was
primarily bought on board for Disney is
to fix all that for them
quite probably but I think there was
also some massive
um financial decisions made by Disney's
the guy that left and particularly if
you look at the I I don't know if these
rumors and I don't 100 understand the
cryptocurrency stuff
but there is a big rumor going around
that Disney and and Paramount massively
invested in that cryptocurrency Scandal
um and when it went almost
nfts the ffts FDX yeah FTX yeah that
lost them a crap load of money and
they're basically trying to cover it up
and but it was him that was the main so
they've brought in
the other guy just sort of like
cover it up a little bit
um but the thing is with Disney they can
paint Pro over a lot of the cracks
because the parks make crap loads of
money in ESPN make crap loads of money
so they can sort of shift one lot and
they always knew catching up with
Netflix is going to be expensive that's
why they bought Fox
you know they bought it for content
so they knew they were going to make
loose money but what they didn't know
was
um what they didn't know was that they
were going to then have covid and then
go through a cost of living crisis yeah
or Disney's losses are even more
than they expected but 500 million
dollars a quarter
is insane
um and Paramount as well are in trouble
um because they
um have had decent subscription numbers
for Paramount plus um worldwide but they
had loads of deals like in here in the
UK
um you get Paramount Plus for free if
you have Sky Cinema
um so I actually get Primark plugs for
free
so that created a false image of like
loads of subscriptions but Pam I don't
get any money for it
that's how I had Netflix for the last
like three years I've not paid for it
I'm paying for it now because I'm not
with sky anymore but yeah
Netflix do still get money for that
whereas Paramount plus got a flat rate
Netflix get an amount of money each
subscription
Paramount plus didn't do that deal they
did a deal that was like we're gonna put
it on us free and this is a flash fee
so it doesn't matter how many
subscribers they're getting away
they're not the idea was that oh it'll
get it out there and lots of people will
see it and then lots of other people
subscribe and it just didn't happen so
Powerman plus is massively in trouble as
well so I mean all of the subscription
services at the moment
but the media
it's just
you saw yesterday that there's
technically a new king of streaming
services right
we were just talking about her whatever
yeah Amazon just overtook Netflix as the
most subscribed streaming service I
guess which is interesting so hopefully
that means that they're stable in in the
movie and TV realm but I did leave a
story it's not 100 True is it though
because they're not quite sure it
depends how you look at the numbers
because the problem is with streamer
services and Netflix is they're
notoriously
um secretive about all the different
numbers and how many subscribers they've
got and everything so um but the one
thing I do like about Amazon and I see
this Jenny spoke about this yesterday as
well actually is that Amazon really put
themselves into the vision to be like
the Hub
streaming service for everybody
particularly worldwide that you can
access everything else through Amazon
um and all the movies with everything
you can sports events everything you can
get through Amazon so they're like they
are becoming the go-to place Disney is
great for Content they've got probably
the best content of all of them and for
me I probably watch Disney more than
anything
um Netflix I think has improved for the
last two years so it's really going
downhill but it seems to have really
pulled the socks the past couple years
um
bought Amazon even though I probably
watch it the least it's probably where I
go through to watch everything
and so they know what I'm watching
because I'm watching through Amazon all
the time you know I got my fire stick in
the back of the TV and that's where I
access all my Netflix and everything
through that
I think one of the reasons why Amazon's
probably taken over the likes of Netflix
and stuff as well as as you say you can
go through and watch everything else but
there's other services available like
you can with Amazon Prime you watch all
your live sports but mostly the thing
that most people will have Prime for is
free delivery
so they may not even be watching Prime
video they may not even be watching any
of the offerings that are content-wise
but they are going to be subscribed
because of free delivery cost of living
like Crisis going on right now
that's the one that they're not gonna um
cancel because of it's free delivery
didn't want to spend an extra like two
like two quid or whatever every time you
buy something because where you're going
to buy it from Amazon yeah it's seven
quid like eight 7.99 or something isn't
it so you might as well yeah add them
quick yeah
then the people will then do things like
with MGM plus so one being told
basically is that in America size if
stargate's aren't it'll be on in America
it'll be on MGM plus because that's
where they're going to focus America
they're going to focus mgm's new
products
worldwide it'll go into Prime because
MGM MGM plus will go on here but it's
five pound more and Amazon apparently
doesn't think people will pay for as
well it'll be a bit like I'm already
paying for Amazon I'm going to pay for
this add-on as well no but it's already
you can already pay for MGM as an
additional already so they're probably
already looking at the numbers and
seeing that no one's buying it
long term they if MGM plus succeeds
they'll want it to promote it as its own
channel worldwide but at the moment it's
nothing but I don't see that we're going
to see more stream Services I obviously
think the next two three years we're
going to see an amalgamation of TV
services I I Paramount Plus for me when
they went when they decided to get rid
of CBS well they should have just done
was gone actually you know what Netflix
you fancy merging
how about we just we you you watch you
have Star Trek and everything anyway
why don't we just do a deal we'll have
we can keep CBS all access here but how
about you become Netflix Paramount or
whatever and we merge and I think they
would have because Netflix wouldn't have
crazy for that all the Paramount movies
and things yeah
the Streetman services that band
together and combine their libraries and
things so they're the ones that are
going to do well in the future but
that's what I think anyway because
I've just said that there's a cost to
live in crisis people are canceling
things left right and Center all the
amount of streaming services you've got
available now it's if you have all of
them it's basically the cost of cable
and people don't want to pay for cable
because there's loads of channels that
they're not watching so link their cats
they're canceling all these different
services
but the ones that are going to combine
if let's say let's see if we go on
Netflix and Amazon they combine forces
people would pay that subscription it
may be slightly more than a Netflix and
an Amazon subscription maybe it'll be 10
pound a month rather than seven pounds
but people would buy that and that would
be the one that succeeds
well you know
I mean there's all these other channels
that are streaming that has quality
content
um they're just ad supported you know
I'm thinking of comment I'm thinking of
Pluto TV 2B and
I mean the the consumers just slathered
in streaming services and content you
know and if you do want to watch the
very latest episode of
you know uh Brave New worlds or whatever
you're gonna have to go
and watch Paramount plus but at some
point in time
I the
the properties there's just these
intellectual properties are going to
have to be Consolidated in some way
I mean because there's
I don't know I mean this last week in
terms of streaming services I watched
watched I Heart Radio because I just had
classical you know on at my desk all
week there's plain in the background you
know
and um that's
ad supported I mean I don't pay anything
for that
um so it it it's it's really a big
problem especially with the big creators
like Paramount on HBO so that it
actually produce high quality television
allegedly that that they're going to
have to figure out another some other
scheme for Paramount plus you know
they've got all the CBS content you know
and
I mean that's cool that's fine but you
know uh
you know all I I I'm just not a Jeopardy
fan you know I mean there's lots of
things on there just because of CVS it's
cool and everything but I don't watch
everything that is on that CBS has to
offer hardly anything
you know there's a reason why Disney
bought Fox
yeah yeah yeah on its own
The Simpsons I get it you know I I
didn't I had Disney Plus for a year
before the fox deal went sort of was
finalized and I didn't watch it once I
had it basically because they had a deal
it was like 40 quid or something for the
year and I was like brilliant all these
new Marvel shows are coming out and then
they didn't come out for like two years
but um but I got it didn't watch it I
didn't watch it once sister for kids
movies basically there wasn't a lot else
on it and then Fox hit the stars and all
these other sort of like sub channels
and it's like but I don't think with
Amazon then I think they're missing a
trick a little bit and I know they're
not but too Fair they're not missing the
trick they're already doing it
excuse me they're doing like the freebie
which is free to view TV shows they've
already got their own TV shows on there
yeah and they have movies and things but
they have adverts
you pay for your Prime and then you have
all these channels underneath that have
adverts on them and you're getting the
Best of Both Worlds as far as your
Amazon you're getting paid twice you've
got like The Best of Both Worlds of a
commercial television channel and have
it advertising
and then you've got streaming service
over the top where you put
Prime content so that'll be the reason
why you go but then you get all this
free stuff underneath
and that's what they're doing they're
Geniuses is Amazon Prime itself
essentially going to turn into Prime
freebie and MGM Plus
and a bunch of other ones
I mean there's there's several other sub
channels as well so what else did you
get through Amazon
um so um what's us just become Stars
just became um
uh Lionsgate did it Lionsgate plus
another one I can't keep track you keep
more track than I I can't I mean you
know you're hot and heavy on it I mean
there's too much for me to absorbers
like oh what
HBO Max over here really in the UK is
basically Sky Atlantic they had a deal
years ago HBO Max didn't want to spread
and have more streaming services over
here so Sky paper so all HBO Max TV
shows got straight to Sky Atlantic here
but they do it like a separate channel
so it's a sky Channel but you have to
pay a little bit extra for it
instead of a stream service then they've
gone all the catch up and it's sort of
like part streaming part normal Channel
sort of things it's a bit like a bit of
both you can either watch it at nine
o'clock in a Monday with the adverts or
you can download it do they still do HBO
now and HBO Go in like Europe I guess or
just strictly Sky Atlantic we haven't
got it
um it's just the HBO stuff ends up on
skylantic
channels get it as well to be fair they
do sell all the main ones Game of
Thrones Sky Atlantic
um way of the Dragons Sky Atlantic and
then you'll get the odd HBO show and
other other channels but mostly it goes
on Sky Atlantic
well what's the Financial Health of Hulu
these days
we're gonna get merged into Disney plus
right eventually but but will it because
NBC owns 25 of the company or 15 of the
company enough to screw Disney over or
at least raise their price high enough
where Disney might not want to pay that
much
here's why I ask it you know I've got um
I've got Hulu I got it in
2016-2017 with my uh Sprint telephone
plan for free
and Sprint's gone away now it's T-Mobile
and I'm still getting it for I haven't
paid a nickel for Hulu for
almost you know half a decade and it's
like don't tell anybody publicly yeah I
mean just out of yourself I mean yeah
you're gonna build tomorrow for 10 years
worth of Hulu
um but so again I think that's that's
that's the way things are going but with
Skye then
um sorry with with star game I did get a
cinema release
I was gonna what sort of budget would
you expect for them to to do that from
remember in a franchise it hasn't been
on our screens for like 15 years that
you know they're going to need a massive
portion of the budget for advertising
yeah
just to get it like the hype to get the
numbers in initially so yeah I don't
know
a billion dollars depends on how
confident they are on it because they're
really confident and want that big old
series to come back with movies and
television shows etc etc
they would put a lot of money into it
but if they're if they treat it kind of
like I mean stargate's awesome and great
but it's always been made
fairly cheaply I guess it
so if they kind of Follow That same
model
day
I don't know it depends how they treat
it how confident they are in it if
they're confident they'll spend a bunch
of money if they're not
same old Stargate in a lot of ways maybe
but
I don't know I I feel like they could go
either way
okay let's say we'll get to January 15th
there's an announcement Stargate are
going to do a movie and they've got a
budget of 100 million dollars
what's your confidence rate and then for
the franchise
remember 100 million dollars 15 years
ago
was a crapload of money yeah
um
well hunt these days 100 million dollars
if you're doing something like Stargate
it's going to take place entirely in the
library
[Laughter]
you know it I mean for something that
says nothing will happen off screen oh
look at that right yeah yeah you know
it'll be one like one of those uh
Stargate episodes you know where it's
just all some of the background
characters like some of the scientists
you know they're like oh yeah uh they're
over there look at them they're talking
about just look can you imagine how cool
it is to be them and it'll it'll just be
those two guys you know watching uh
Daniel walk in and out of the library
and just theorizing on what all the hell
is going on yeah that'll be a 100
million dollars right there yeah yeah
okay then Harris 200 million dollars
I think they could manage with the 100
million dollars ion is if they go
cheaper I'm I would think they'd
probably give it like an 85 to 100. but
if they if they had to spend some money
150 to like 250 would be a
great sweet spot I think what was it
what was the budget of the expanse so
season of the expense what's the budget
of that they spent about nine million
dollars an episode
so can it's and you're still pushing 100
million dollars for the season of the
expanse right that was a considered a
reasonably cheap it averaged at eight to
nine million dollars well I mean you
know yeah I mean you can have an effects
heavy show you know you can do you know
90 minutes two hours of production and
clearly come in under the 100 million
dollar Park but if you have Jace Momoa
that there goes half your budget right
there you know so it depends on what the
above line costs are I think of how much
effects you have
so I don't know I mean I think they can
do it for 100 million even not including
marketing
um yeah production cost yeah yeah yeah
yeah
I mean you said Momoa real quick and
that just make makes me think because
he's got to be expensive to a degree but
he can't be all that expensive with the
amount of TV shows he makes and I mean
Slumberland that new movie he made for
Netflix fantastic I still haven't seen
it it looks really good but I mean it
was advertised decently well but Netflix
doesn't really advertise our movies and
they are notorious for tossing money at
things but
I can't imagine he got paid exuberantly
for Slumberland
he might kind of be the guy to go to
because he does those smaller TV shows
and things like that and if he has a
love for Stargate still he might come
back for a little bit lower of a price
take a percentage instead okay
take a percentage twice
he won't
I was just going to say a lot of his
co-stars from C uh were also you know
with him in Stargate Atlantis
yeah yeah yeah
um so I think it's possible and you know
um
uh yeah I also Ian's all right he's got
his pulse on I read that too and uh
I know I think it's possible I think
I mean he did have the two you know the
big you know the DC movies he's got
those under his belt
but I mean it's still you know even with
if you look at the budget of C or or
Frontier or whatever
you know I I don't want to call him a B
list actor by any Source but he still I
mean it's still pricey I mean if you're
getting decent room recognized cast
you know then you're you're going to pay
you're gonna pay for it
yeah true I mean that's that's what I'm
saying about we don't want an A-list to
stop really I mean chasing my mode don't
get me wrong would be amazing and if I
did bring him online I would say he's
getting an executive producer title he's
getting something else he's got you know
he's not he's not just coming into Act
yeah he would have to want to do it
though he would have to be desperate to
do it and Jason Momoa seems to like to
do lots of different projects he doesn't
do anything for very long
um but he's done a couple of movies over
time so he's basically he did that one
movie he basically wrote it and did
everything to get it on the things I
can't always call it was with his dad
and uh whatever
um but he does lots of projects like
that but like even C which is a labor of
love for him he said three seasons done
that's it you know I thought were
desperate for everyone here
Frontier yeah and so
I've I've I have heard rumors about
Jason Momoa
um but I've never heard anything that
was concrete other than him mention it
in an interview once
um about six months ago and but it was
sort of like it was very much a
throwaway comment it was like you know
somebody said if you know what sort of
projects would you you know if Stargate
come back anyway I'd love to do that
[ __ ] and yeah I think a lot of that
rumor came from
um and then obviously people have asked
because so many people go into like
David Hugh letting everybody go from
starting you so they ask him about
Stargate and that's how that rumor
started I think
um I've never heard anything solid from
the people I speak to I I genuinely
think they probably think they couldn't
get him
I would I'd be amazed if I was never
even asked
because they wouldn't they just mean
they couldn't get him see he's a great
actor but he's really only been in three
movies that have made a bunch of money
or I guess two movies Aquaman and dune
besides that he's it's kind of like the
rock he's he's a big guy but
Black Adam was by far the most money The
Rock has ever made at box office he
always is successful but not Uber
successful MMO is kind of a degree lower
than that because he still does a bunch
of great cheaper action movies that are
probably in that 80 to 100 120 million
dollar budget range
might be up the alley I don't know
fingers crossed
well the other side of it because it's
like I I hear contradictory rumors
sometimes like say um I say this Jenny
Steven talks talked about this yesterday
because depending who you talk to you
get different opinions and but it's
because up until
hint in for a future video up until very
recently Stargate hadn't decided what
they were doing I'm missing hand decided
what they were doing
um so they had their options open so
some people talk about a series over a
movie some people say the movie of you
know what I mean
is there an argument though to say and
actually a TV series
then a movie is the better option
because you can set a foundation with a
TV series you just can't do with a movie
and like somebody mentioned earlier and
I actually mentioned when I was talking
about Avatar too the cinema isn't the
big draw the big gravitas thing that it
used to be
yeah
um it's not as important as it used to
be
so is there an argument for saying a TV
series is a better plan
well series nowadays are pretty much
mini movies aren't they
yeah so there is the argument to be made
that you could have a 10 10 episode
series and it will you can get more of a
story out than you could in one single
movie
but
I don't know I think a movie would
I think a movie would be slightly better
because I think I don't know I guess I'm
a little bit old-fashioned in that way
that it's
a movie is massive and it would have
more of a I guess I just put more into
like uh promotion and stuff so more and
more people we're going back to the
cross-pollination thing
you'd have the the core audience of
Stargate fans you love who love the show
but then you'd have the general sci-fi
fans who'd see it and go oh I remember
watching Stargate the movie back in 94
maybe that'd be pretty good to watch the
new one and then they might ReDiscover
the series and
Get It
Go that go that kind of route but I
don't know there is an argument to be
made that the uh
a series would be better because you've
got more more scope to tell a longer
more in-depth story but I don't know if
you want something that's more bang
we're back I think a movie is the way to
go
Harris I kind of agree but I but I I I I
think I agree for the most part I see
both sides if Amazon were to do the
series and
they they really don't have to pay as
much as we think of to promote things
because I mean every time you order an
Amazon package when rings of power was
on what was on the package of power
that's true anybody wondering anything
is going to have Stargate on their stuff
for the a month two months three months
however long it's running
so that'll be baked in advertising which
would hopefully put eyes and asses on on
the screen and in seats you know but
I if they go the movie route I feel it's
not necessarily necessary but it does
show that they're willing and and
capable hopefully of elevating the
content and and making a film out of it
and and really putting all all of their
effort into it and not necessarily all
right we'll we'll put
put a series out and then uh we'll
advertise it on Amazon Prime and people
do packages because I I like that if you
have that capability of doing things do
it you know
but I feel like a movie would be
elevated
in a way does that make sense yeah yeah
you know it's almost like you know a
movie still has this uh Mystique about
it this uh this air of
of
um really big spectacle you know
whereas you know something they're still
on the streaming just television kind of
doesn't
uh and it's still you know going to the
movies is still kind of a group
experience still kinda
um
but you know if
if we're looking at you know long-term
viability of the franchise
you know you know do we want you know
one movie and then maybe get a series or
do we want five seasons and no movie you
know something like that I'd rather have
the TV
you know because it still
more story you know
I haven't gotten to I haven't finished
sg1 or I guess SGA yet and I know both
have movies that come off of them so
Stargate literally has done movie to TV
and TV to movie
so it really has the options I guess how
successful were those Stargate movies
when they were coming out did they go
straight to TV were they yeah to be
honest straight to DVD but they did do
quite well okay it's good sales but then
they went to think but there was a
reason why we didn't get a third SG
movie DVD sales were starting to drop
off
so um yeah but the reason why we can get
the third one they didn't make this much
money but again we were supposed to get
a Stargate advantis a great TV movie and
we never got it Extinction okay and the
under third or fourth I guess
and the movies didn't have that
spectacle of a film of something it
released in December you know something
inspectional um
you know I'm referring to something
that's got the like the quality of Dune
you know yeah yeah gotta go see it in
the theater because of the just the
Avatar is another one of those spectacle
movies and I'm just wondering yeah
they would have to spend a butt ton of
money to get to that spectacle to make
use of the the the the form of a theater
you know and I'd rather have you know
three seasons everything was to be
bigger though doesn't it you know after
that that old story about JJ Abrams and
when he did the Enterprise the
Enterprise a and the JJ Abrams movies is
enormous compared to the rest of the
Star Treks and you know if you actually
look at the you know because our geeky
we are I think engine I mean it's just
longer it's got this right thing and
it's enormous because James Abrams went
it's gonna look stupid on an IMAX we've
got to make it much bigger but in a in a
film in a you know on the cinema
everything's other sets are bigger the
cameras they use and the technology use
is bigger you know it's like it's that's
why these things cost a lot more money
than they do and the TV screens because
I mean yeah
the the you know in terms of uh Lord of
the Rings
you know Peter Jackson's models were 12
feet tall you know he called them bigger
church because they were just
you know you don't you you don't get
that with uh help
no no
um I I honestly think that if they do Go
the movie route
it's because I I would be massively
excited by that because I actually don't
think the movie will make as much money
as it would have done 10 years ago and
it's similar to the argument I said with
Avatar there's no DVD sales afterwards
yeah it would just go straight to
streaming so it's only going to make
what it makes a thing but if they went
200 million dollars did a movie I would
go if they're serious about the
franchise
because they're not doing this for money
you know obviously they will make money
but they're doing it because they want
to kick off the franchise in a big
display and I think that's the main
reason for Cinema now because that
because of everything you guys just said
it's still got that gravitas it's still
movie stars isn't it you know it's still
even though movie stars appear on
screaming series now all the time
um it's still the movie star the
a-lister the big Cinema release and I
think Amazon want to take that next step
they don't want to do
you know 20 movies a year they'll just
go straight to Amazon
you know they don't want to be Netflix
they want to be a big movie studio and
that's why they bought MGM
yeah it's because they wanted that
they want that respecter that goes with
the MGM logo yeah
I think also the making a movie first
it would be better for audiences overall
um to get them excited and then move
them on to a series because if you think
about the movies we've already had for
Stargate yes we have the original
Stargate movie that was what basically
kicked off the entire franchise to begin
with and then we got a series but then
the other movies we got were straight to
DVD they they would never have done well
if they went to cinema because there's
so much backstory that if they went out
to the cinema
let's let's take Arc of Truth for
example
that's the conclusion for the Ori
storyline if that was in the movie in
the theaters
they'd have advertised it blah blah blah
blah people went to see it and went well
who the who juliori who were these guys
what's this what's going on
yeah
if they kick-starting the series again
like a kind of like a reboot of
refreshing the interest kind of thing
make a movie get everyone excited and
then make a series and I think that that
will just do loads better
you know one thing I thought would be an
interesting premise for this problem you
know the new Stargate movie let's say
one of the new one of the uh human
civilizations
out there in the stars that you know
were transported off Earth they were
enslaved and they revolted but but
they're rediscovering the gate let's say
the gate was lost to them for a long
time and this other civilization totally
yeah
I think Harris has had relations with a
woman since we started the extreme yeah
uh yeah it's yeah I just responded to
the guy I said most not my friend three
of us are married in here and I live in
Los Angeles in my mid-20s guess again
like
she was just like call our wives
but anyway come on tell me what were you
saying I was talking about now oh yeah
yeah so what if there's this other human
civilization out there you know
and they're going along and they're
starting to explore they got from their
point of view then all of a sudden they
you know walks into Admiral Carter
coming through the Stargate on another
world all together
you know
they're going they're going to bring
back General Carter she's so coming back
um General excuse me not Admiral General
Carter yeah
goes into this this thing about having
to bring in more than just the core fans
right because Amazon don't really care
about Gators if you think about it from
a practical marketing point of view they
know they've got us by the short and
curlies already yeah I'm not thinking
about that they're thinking how do we
bring in more than just the Stargate
fans
so that goes into Canon now right so we
know with new track they were a bit
faster loose with Canon
um I keep calling it like a hybrid
way of doing it that they pick and
choose Canon and they pick and choose
the bits that work and they forget about
the bits they don't
and particularly with Star Trek it was
running so long there was so much Cannon
and so much contradicted each other over
the years and that they sort of had to
they sort of had to go now if if we do
everything it's just going to get so
confusing we can't our hands are so
tired if we stick the cannon really
religiously so we've got it
I think with Marvel
they were brilliant at picking and
choosing what can they stick with I mean
a big example I can think of is the
Mandalore if not the Mandalorian the
Mandarin
I'm gonna go talk about Star Wars in a
second the Mandarin how they had the
Mandarin character from comic they
realized that would be a bit silly so
they came up with this clever little
twist and did the Ben Kingsley thing and
people went uh we're gonna a lot of
comic book fans went how can I help you
know that's not right but actually it
really worked for the franchise
do we think stargate's gonna have to do
something like that for it to work not
just for the Gators we're not just
thinking about this because obviously
Amazon don't give a [ __ ] to us but to
attract a wider audience
yeah they're definitely definitely need
to attract a wider audience because yeah
not to be rude but a lot of the Stargate
fans are really old
like I'm a young Stargate fan
this guy's ass
I said not to be rude
[Laughter]
what color is my beard again I keep
forgetting foreign
[Music]
capitalize on
new fresh sexier audiences I guess
but God I don't I don't really want to
do what they did with Stargate Universe
and make the entire cast like young and
sexy and I wanted to be kind of
realistic in a way shut up I want young
and sexy
but that's not what Stargate was about I
mean we had Samantha Carter yeah we had
some sex appeal in Stargate but we
didn't have everyone being like
chichis or jaws and like
did you see the topic Teeth did you see
every school that every walk
okra it was just like yes there's only
one okra only one poker
I don't know
the blokes weren't much to look at I'll
give you that and the only guy with the
Chisel jaw that I can think of is that
guy uh uh what's the zipakner so Parkway
with the punchable face
um
I've got what we're talking about yeah
but is that no yeah they are gonna have
to do that but I'm bringing young but
but is that I mean have you really just
put into a nutshell why Brad Wright
didn't get the gig
I reckon so I reckon that's probably one
of the biggest reasons he's an older
gentleman with class I don't know he's
probably going to be wanting to do what
they did back then but audiences are a
lot different to what they were back
then now so
does that mean you shouldn't come out as
an architect
oh wait your Latrell as well yeah but I
was talking about SG-1
if we're talking about SGA oh
Jennifer Keller oh
[Laughter]
I'm an idiot
um uh who is the doctor from Stargate
Atlantis this was in Firefly our door
she was um
oh I love her so much I've got Google
who are you talking but um yeah
um no no no no no no no no no no no I'm
still in season one
um was it river river town was that her
name okay
I was so close some are glad she's
beautiful
I'm not oh she's adorable
um
but but yeah I mean I I I think they've
got to I do think that's why Brad didn't
get the gig I think they're thinking
they they don't care about the core
Gators they they've just gone straight
away how do we get more people is Brad
the right the person to do that probably
not well the fans well the Gators be up
for that of course do we care about them
no we've got them anyway
yeah because they know they know
even if we're going to complain there's
no Brad right blah blah we're still
going to watch it because it's Stargate
I've said this so many times on the
channel we're still gonna watch it and
everyone who complains is not going to
watch it yes you are you know you are
they have all of us baked in and then I
mean
I think do you know it it's in my
vocabulary a little too well I'm cute
This Is How We Do It
but uh
the same same way don't kill me story
but rings of power was not universally
loved per se cut him off I'm just good
right now I don't know who that is
these young people these days but it is
still the most viewed series ever more
so than the house of the Dragon which
beat Game of Thrones highest viewing
series ever I've never talked about that
you know so if Stargate gets advertised
that same way everybody gets a package
how many just people are gonna be like
well what's this let me check it out
because they did it for rings of power I
don't know if that let them down so
maybe they won't go but
state was in SGA Summer Glau was in
Terminator yeah she was the Sarah Connor
Chronicles yes Sarah Connor Chronicles
um she's also lovely but but yes I'll
just I'll just find all these names
going up in the in the channel oh yeah
I ate a bug
that's lying everything anyway
um so I was gonna say we're talking
about the hybrid thing though like
Marvel did it brilliantly I thought
early on not so not super well recently
we've had that discussion Star Wars kind
of did it as well as well that they had
only space to Cannon and all this stuff
going on and they just decided you know
with the new TV stuff goes all right
we're gonna forget that happened and
we're gonna just concentrate on this
Cannon and that's it now and we're
marching forwards and a lot of Star Wars
fans kind of lost their ship for a bit
like there's an element there though but
just wait wait and see and it'll be
awesome and I actually think the TV at
least is freaking awesome
um they had to get the story line
straight for it to work going forwards
and that does mean something you have to
sacrifice stuff and when you've got
10 15 17 series of a TV show with 20
episodes per season that's a lot of
stuff that's gonna just step on you know
that's a lot of Canon to step on
sometimes you've got to pick and choose
I think
well as as your resident Star Wars fan
here uh
yes everything you just said about Star
Wars yes because the series are great
and and they're definitely kind of
holding to a very specific Canon but
people were pissed off at Disney prior
to being pissed off about the movies
because when Disney bought Star Wars
they said same thing James Gunn just
said with DC everything whether it's
Comics whether it's books whether it's
video games whether it's movies it's all
Canon
and they stopped that really quickly the
video games in the movies still
technically all canon in the TV shows
technically all Canon but
as much as I love old Dave filoni the
guy that's behind a lot of the TVs he he
just tosses his comic book stuff out the
window toss his books out the window
which
is odd because Disney made it such a
prevalent thing to okay you want to buy
the books you want to buy this at a
certain point you're asking why am I
buying the books if you're going to
change it in the TV show so then people
stop buying the books and they get angry
that nobody's buying High Republic and I
mean it's a complicated little
scenario but they kind of shot
themselves in the foot in the process of
doing it but I mean with Star Trek
actually I was always a Trekkie before I
hit Stargate with Star Trek it was
always there was the beta Cannon and it
was different the books of beta Cannon
it's not the same if it doesn't appear
on screen it didn't happen
you know and I know why I don't know why
Star Wars just didn't do the same sort
of thing but look what's on screen
happened everything else is lovely but
it's not much better than fanfiction
let's just crack on
well they turned all of the the books in
Star Wars into uh Legends didn't they
yeah so it was it was all Canon but then
they just said oh no now it's Legend so
you could kind of look at it as oh it's
like an alternate timeline kind of thing
or it's an alternate universe kind of
thing
yes but also after 2015 all of those
books were supposed to be Canon so then
they did it again
that's when they were Disney bought it
and all the Legends
yeah that's what people were pissed off
about all the legend stuff that pissed
people off enough were like okay so all
the videos we've been reading for the
past 30 years don't mean anything now
okay well Disney's gonna be in charge
we're bringing you new books they did
that and then it feels like some of the
TV shows great I love all the TV shows
but some of it is kind of fan fiction
like in a way because they're literally
borrowing from the books but taking what
they want and then adding things
necessary for the shows which is great
but come up with an original idea and
let that be a beta Cannon let that be a
Legends Canon let that be somewhere
you know
no I'm with you and I I don't think
Stargate has as much of a problem though
as like Star Trek Star Wars is it
because people I don't think there is as
much material Star Trek had a real
problem because it spanned 40 50 years
before new track came out and the movies
and everything else they've had a real
problem and JJ Abrams though took that
problem and just tore it up and went way
I could do what I want Royal balls
um black holes black holes are a good
way of going from one place to another
right I I heard something about black
holes and time travel let's go with that
[ __ ] and and just made a difference if
they do something like that with
Stargate and people will always get into
the comments and they always say
alternative Universe we can do it three
star okay it's happened we're in the
mirror universities do that
I I might throw up a kidney if they do
that
it'll it'll drive me up the wall the
problem with that kind of stuff with
black holes and mirror universities is
it has been done in Stargate before so
if you
use it as an excuse It's just like it's
a cop-out because it's it's like it's
that was already established in the
series now you're just making it an
excuse to to get rid of everything that
come before it like it's because a lot
of sci-fi a lot of sci-fi elements have
already been done in Stargate
this could be very hard for them to get
away with explaining away Canon
yeah if you know what I mean
which is madness but they can't use
pseudoscience because it's already been
used in Canon if they do a Star Trek
they'll go all turn up and they look
completely different
I I think we have a right then to lose
that [ __ ]
um and and that's what 15 year old comes
up with glowing eyes you're like you
you've not been alive for 5 000 years
changed repeatedly the change I've got
to remember that the Klingons changed
for the Next Generation they were
completely different to what we've seen
before so actually
um
never mind Star Trek's always done that
so I don't know we should get stressed
about it but Stargate cousin Stargate is
pretty clean from a Canon point of view
it's probably the best the only one of
the very few franchises that is pretty
clean there aren't any major Canon
fuckups
we have to understand like back in the
day when it was first on you know on the
Sci-Fi channel
I mean it
ruled you know I mean it even though it
was on cable only you know on Sci-fi
channel
I mean in terms of
impact in term you know science fiction
impact it had a very high score I think
I mean it was very foundational I mean
everybody was catching uh Stargate
whatever the iteration yeah you know it
was heavily promoted by the Sci-Fi
channel and it did very very well
at 10 seasons broke records yeah and I
think one problem we have now is you
know it's it's been a good hot minute
since it's actually been a new series on
television and uh there's a lot of
viewers you know that are in their 20s
that have that were never around Harris
when it was actually on new you know I
mean it's like Mama's eye over in Texas
it's like
um Deep Space Nine is that was it was
like 20 years old now
since his first airing I mean a lot of
these shows that we've iterate and we
talk about all the damn time
Our Deck any gold
Harris I'm not about bringing a lot of
that back for the new Star Trek God
series and I'm like people haven't
watched Deep Space Nine for years and
you're going to bring Cisco back and
think people are going to know what the
hell are you talking about yeah
yeah but anyway right guys we are over
the hour mark I think that's been
a brilliant little chat thank you very
much can I bring you one more thing go
for it why not okay
so we were talking earlier about the
Witcher
what do we think about blood origin
I can't wait Michelle using it I mean
yes in the conversation yes she is oh my
God I can barely I think that's
Netflix's Big Show for this Christmas
you know traditionally everyone does
like something big for Christmas it's
airing Christmas Day
is it really yeah oh Christmas Eve
Christmas Eve or Christmas Day that's
their big thing there yeah and Michelle
yo God damn anything a daughter
so can't wait can't wait
do you think it's fun to uh
is living real Stargate okay so are we
gonna I mean do we think that um
you know blood origin is going to make
up for the loss of uh the loss of Cavill
in Witcher Prime nope
[Music]
I I don't think it's down for more than
one season yet is it
I don't know I don't know
it's like a special series or something
no I think it's a standalone series at
the moment I mean it's a special
presentation or something it's not like
they're not billing it as a normal
series but it's just like because you
guys give me just one second sir
you know stuff stuff okay
so
Matt you said at the very beginning that
you saw a bunch of stuff this week for
once what were you watching
oh it was uh it was it was Wednesday
that's literally what I've been watching
all week yeah we spoke about it already
but yeah I loved it
good so so should I watch Wednesday of
the peripheral first because I'm
debating both Wednesday's only eight
episodes so you can get through that in
a day or two yeah peripheral those
episodes are long
in terms of
plot
when you think an hour long as well I
was listening
um thank you
um but Wednesday's more fun isn't it
yeah professionals much more
um intellectual yeah and then miss when
you're watching it message me when you
realize the twist
or Wednesday yeah referral okay okay
when you realize what's going on
I just I just want to see how clever I
am at what point I realized and I went
to my friend ah it's uh
um
prior to watching the episodes It's not
none of that it's
good did you say don't take dabs
prior to the episode
from that final episode and just oh my
God right you'll think Wednesday's
coming out of the TV ring style if you
uh have anything recreational before
watching that either so sounds fun
but guys thank you so much I really
enjoyed that I like to say after that
Stargate
um I've forgotten the channel enter the
gate enter the gate is that right
dialogue yesterday come on man get with
it they're awesome Mr David Reed himself
um I'd like to say I got messages going
you should talk to them again so
obviously I've been really looking
forward to doing this video now because
because
um no we've got a brilliant Community
here and you know it's um these
conversations
highlight of my week
not you Matt
stormy and Harris though you guys are
[ __ ] great I love you guys in
California
now even people in the comments are
telling me to shut up now thanks to you
Jay
yeah Jay it's pretty funny they're quick
on it too
I don't even have to start anything like
normally it'll just appear so um I I get
comments on your on your videos with
your Tuesday videos you get constant
shut up
um but no honestly brilliant um this
week I've got a couple of videos coming
up with Stargate with some of the news I
have hearing particularly one rumor
that's if true is insanely excited
actually
it just feels like everything's coming
together right now
um and Jenny stiven as I like said at
the end of that video yesterday she
actually said
I will do this again in March or April
we might want to do it in January so
you know and she's coming from a
position of knowing a little bit more
than than we do you know I I see
um I I I'm like looking you know you get
those paper and get a hole and you look
through the hole and you can see just
like that little narrow image like I'm
seeing little snapshots of what's going
on and Behind These doors and um it just
could make me laugh as well how many
times I get told things and I've not
understood what I'm being told and then
I'll get a message where you can go
that's not what I meant [ __ ] it'll
be like don't know the industry they'll
use terminology and I'm like I
because just come in the [ __ ] video
and you explain it to them because no
I'll lose my job okay
um but you know she actually understands
these things so when she's
telling me as well that everything I've
been told is true that just like makes
me more excited especially with the
a new Stargate in the New Year how cool
would that be it would be awesome
and we will go live if it happens when
I'm in New York I'm going to lose my
[ __ ]
so that will really do my ending it'll
be off with you wherever we are no
matter what time it is even if you're at
work
we're going live we're going live yeah
what are you doing shut up I'll be there
in the office and my boss what are you
doing I'm just going live because
Stargate is out
now we definitely should have a watch
party
uh when when the new series hits mate
we're gonna we'll be all over that we
will just we will just watch the news
and do it live and we'll just watch it
and do it live and and yeah and talk
about it straight away because it's
going to be the biggest for me anyway
it's going to be the biggest thing and
you know what you know what scares me
more
than Stargate not happening is it coming
out and it being rubbish
Ed episode comes out and it's no and I
don't like it
yeah
but we talked about Stargate Origins
earlier if that had carried on I
probably still would have still watched
it even though it was crap just because
it's Stargate and I just want Stargate
like yes it's [ __ ] all over Cannon sorry
about the language yes
it poo pooed all over Cannon
but it was Stargate and it was the the
best we've had for like 10 years
all right guys now let's just say thank
you so much for taking your time out on
a Sunday to talk on my little YouTube
channel I really really do appreciate it
thank you everybody knows you've done
great today guys in the audience over
there and um with all the comments I
have now to keep up absolutely brilliant
thank you so much everybody there and
guys we will be back next week but then
we're probably gonna go and break
probably over Christmas so we might not
be live over the Christmas period
goodbye Christmas we kind of spend time
with our families
oh no I haven't thought about that
have a violent night you know
what I love I don't know I'm trying to
find it I want to watch it with the kids
you may want to come down the chimney
yeah
um actually mate you're right as soon as
I break up from Molly I'm just going
live and staying alive for like three
days straight
um
but anyway
they follow me so let me appear around
the corner Harris is gone but guys we're
always back
say goodbye everybody goodbye everybody
bye everybody
see y'all
y'all see you later guys uh watch out
for new videos this week a couple of
really big ones coming see you later
[Music]